oh bonjour mesdames messieurs les jours et les gays,
les éditeurs de la bande-annonce ont brûlé
l'huile de minuit et j'avoue que ça a l'
air plutôt bien avec tous les
effets sonores de Pew et la musique est comme si je
suis tellement excité de partager avec vous la
bande-annonce de la saison de Harley Quinn  trois à
venir à HBO Max
Gotham City
c'est une montée maintenant
ma maison a besoin de Nightwing euh quelqu'un
veut changer de siège
Harley et Ivy sont de retour et une fois de plus
notre maison est à la maison ma petite amie a proposé le
plan le plus dur à cuire jamais frappé
Ivy nous sommes  va terraformer Gotham
récupérer chaque centimètre carré des humains grand
plan désolé si ce club semble sarcastique les
gars peignent ma main en jouant au tennis de table de
grands changements vont se produire j'ai essayé d'
être un méchant mais c'est l'ancien moi je
veux être quelqu'un dont ma famille peut être
fière c'est  pourquoi je me présente à la
mairie
désolé je pensais que tu étais prêt pour que
nous fermions les yeux
Gotham City passe au
vert joue encore plus un désastre qu'un
mot de malédiction à peine planifié c'est faux innoc  ent les
gens meurent est-ce juste moi ou il
semble déjà un peu différent je
crois qu'elle traverse ce qu'on
appelle de la merde j'ai pensé à faire
ça ensemble Harley tu as changé le
tue pour la contredire ne lisez
pas dedans
flux noir
Je l'ai fait avec succès
maintenant je ne vais pas répéter ce que cette
plante a dit mais il te déteste
tu m'as tué